168 years before game of thrones the
targaryens were at their peak investors
there were many targaryens and even more
dragons from the perspective of every
house in the seven kingdoms major or
minor as well as from the perspective of
commoners and even from the perspective
of targaryens themselves the targaryen
rules seem to be so powerful that even 1
000 years from then on they would still
rule the continent but then the dance of
the dragons happened it was a targaryen
civil war that saw the end of many
targaryens and most of their dragons
it nearly destroyed their entire house
this is one of the most exciting and
most epic events that ever happened in
the history of this world and it's
exactly the event that house of the
dragon will follow therefore it should
not come as a surprise that many main
characters of the show are going to be
the dragon lord ancestors of danny
targaryen and jon snow the series is
based on george r martin's book fire and
blood which covers the entire targaryen
history in westeros starting from aegon
targaryen and his conquest and going to
the dance of the dragons
while fire and blood part 2 will also
cover the blackfyre rebellions and will
end with robert's rebellion the prequel
series house of the dragon finds the
targaryen dynasty at the absolute apex
of its power with around 20 dragons
flying over king's landing and
dragonstone most empires surreal and
imagined crumble from such heights in
the case of the targaryens their slow
fall begins almost 192 years before the
events of game of thrones when king
viserys targaryen breaks with a century
of tradition by naming his daughter
rhaenyra heir to the iron throne but
when viserys later fathers a son
the court is shocked that rhaenyra
retains her status as his heir and seeds
of division so friction across the realm
so basically the show starts with king
viserys the first targaryen sitting on
the iron throne with rhaenyra his oldest
child being his heir instead of his son
aegon much to this pleasure of aegon's
mother queen ellis and hightower through
a series of flashbacks we'll learn about
why king viserys chose to keep rainer as
his designated heir even when he got a
son
we'll also learn about the tension in
the king's landing court between
rhaenyra's faction and alice sats
faction
or in other words between the blacks and
the greens
rhaenyra's faction obviously supports
rhaenyra while alice's faction supports
aegon as the future ruler of westeros
king viserys the first targaryen had
three children by his first queen and
marin
but only one princess rhaenyra survived
to adulthood
lacking a son to succeed him viserys
began to train rhaenyra to be there
young rhaenyra was included in
discussions of the affairs of the state
and was allowed to participate in
meetings of the small council many of
the nobles took note and rhaenyra soon
acquired a huge number of supporters and
real quick i just want to give a quick
shout out and thank you to surf shark
vpn for sponsoring this video and
supporting the channel if you guys don't
know what a vpn is it's virtual private
network
surf shark is a vpn app and browser
extension which basically allows you to
put yourself anywhere in the world you
already heard about the term geoblocking
while netflix or disney plus for example
have different movies for each country
so in the united kingdom or anywhere
else in the world you can decide to go
to the united states because for example
you want to access some content which is
only available within the united states
basically what it does is it allows you
to unlock content on most platforms it
also allows you to encrypt your data and
remain anonymous online you can also use
a web clean add-on to make sure those
malicious sites out there don't
compromise your security use promo code
fire and blood to get 83 off
plus 4 extra months for free they even
offer a 30 day money guarantee if you're
not satisfied the link is in the
description after the passing of queen
emma viserys named rinera is there and
hundreds of lords and landon knights
paid obeisance to her
the king later remarried to ellison
hightower and had four more children
aegon helena amen and daeron
a great tourney was held at king's
landing on the fifth anniversary of
zerus marriage to ellison
during the opening feast queen alicent
wore a green gown while princess
rhaenyra dressed in the red and black of
house targaryen
note was taken and thereafter he became
the custom to refer to greens and blacks
when talking of the queen's party and
the party of the princess respectively
while many expected that the king would
change the succession order and the high
towers tried to persuade him to do so
many times
viserys only strengthened rhaenyra's
place in the succession
by marrying her to sterling or valerian
who himself had targaryen blood through
his mother princess rhaenys
it's not a big spoiler as his character
is not that important but in season 1
laner will be executed but i won't tell
you by who although you'll probably
figure it out and after rainer's husband
gets executed rhaenyra will marry her
uncle prince daemon targaryen younger
brother to viserys this only strengthens
her position even more as daemon himself
has a lot of supporters and is arguably
the best warrior commander and general
of this time in season 1 it will also be
established that alisandes and
rhaenyra's children have hatred towards
each other which will lead to many
horrible events by the time the war
breaks out speaking of the war breaking
out things start to escalate towards the
end of season one
king viserys dies queen ellis and
hightower conceals viserys's death from
the public
and instead has sir kristen cole lord
commander of the kingsguard summoned the
small council to ellison's apartments in
mangrove saltfest grand maester rorweil
here predicts a war
believing that rhaenyra would never be
willing to give up her birthright and
had dragons at her disposal when lyman
declares that he was not willing to
listen to people plotting to steal
rhaenyra's crown and attempts to leave
sir kristen kills him
this makes lymon the first casualty of
the dance of the dragons
after lyman's death the green council
made their plans
wowing their loyalty to their new king
and arresting all those in king's
landing who could be loyal to rhaenyra
to all those who might be loyal to aegon
ravens are sent prince aymond aegon's
brother is sent to storm's end to
betroth himself to one of lord boris
baratheon's daughters so house baratheon
might fight for aegon ii
meanwhile rhaenyra remains on
dragonstone unaware of what happened
instead of coming to king's landing to
claim the throne christian who once
served rhaenyra convinced viserys's son
prince sake on the elder to claim the
rule of the seven kingdoms as his father
lay dead for this he became known as
christian the king maker viserys had
decreed his heir to be rhaenyra
targaryen princess of dragonstone the
daughter from his first wifey marin
the green said the red keeps support egg
on the elder the eldest son of his
second wife alison however and kristen
takes into custody and he blacks
remaining at court
alice sent forbid septons and silent
sisters from treating viserys's body a
week after viserys's death his passing
is finally publicly revealed with the
greens accounting the ascension of aegon
ii targaryen the silent sisters then
prepared the late king's body for the
traditional burning of a targaryen
aegon's coronation is hastily prepared
the dragon pit is chosen as the site for
its towering bronze doors
strong growth and thick walls
making it easily defensible sir kristen
cole crowns aegon while alice sent
hightower crown sagon's sister wife
halena however the night before the
first defection had taken place
sir stefan darkling of the kingsguard
had left the city with amongst other
things the crown worn by kings jahir is
the first and miseries the first and is
taking it to the rightful queen rhaenyra
at dragonstone rhaenyra finds out that
her father died
and aegon staged a coup and was crowned
king in king's landing
furious rhaenyra quickly made her own
council at dragonstone the black council
the participants are amongst others her
uncle husband daemon her three eldest
sons jacaryus lucerus and geoffrey lord
corley solarian and his wife princess
rhaenys rhaenyra is crowned queen using
the crown her father and
great-grandfather had worn
thanks to sir steph and darkling who had
the ride from king's landing
prince damon places the crown on
rhaenyra's head himself and is named the
protector of the realm and jacaryus is
officially named prince of dragonstone
and the heir to the iron throne
during the council it's result that
while rhaenyra remains at dragonstone to
regain her health prince daemon and
characters would travel to the
riverlands to make harry hall their base
and railing point for those loyal to
rhaenyra house valerian would close off
the gallet blocking all shipping from
blackwater bay
rhaenys is convinced that storm's end
would declare for rhaenyra since lord
borman baratheon the deceased father of
lord boris and rhaenys's uncle had
always been a supporter of rhaenys
prince daemon is also convinced that
lady jane irene the maiden of the whale
would bring her support to their side as
rhaenyra's mother was irene herself
although they believed the north to be
too remote to play an important part in
the war
messages are to be sent to those lords
nevertheless with the eldest jacarius
visiting the arranged of the eerie the
man the release of white harbor and the
starks of winterfell
rhaenyra's second son lucerus travels to
storm's end
rhaenyra proclaims king aegon and his
mother queen alicent as well as their
supporters traitors and the enemy of
house targaryen
back at king's landing at this point
already a king aegon proclaims rhaenyra
traitor and the enemy of house targaryen
and thus the targaryen civil war starts
dragons will dance swords will clash
monarchs will rise and fall and season 1
will end
leaving you to impatiently wait for
season 2 to see what happens next
basically the house of the dragon is
focused on the war of succession between
aegon ii and his half-sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
round the war that will be fought from
129 ac to 131ac
it will see the deaths of monarchs the
deaths of targaryens and their dragons
as well as major battles across the
seven kingdoms with the starks and the
valerians fighting the hardest on
rhaenyra's side and the lannisters and
baratheons fighting the hardest on
aegon's side all of this and more you
will see in 2022 on hbo thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
i hope to see you in the next one peace